federal investigators are trying to
determine what caused a deadly cargo
plane crash in Texas the Atlas air jet
was carrying packages for Amazon's
premiere from Florida when it went down
in a marshy area near Houston Saturday
all three people on board were killed
Kris Van Cleave went to the crash site
where teams are trying to locate the
black boxes just twisted and mangled
pieces of Atlas Air flight 30 591 remain
Atlas pilots captain Rick Blakely and
Conrad Aska died in the crash so did
Shawn Archuleta a Mesa Airlines captain
he hitched a ride on the Boeing 767 to
get to work in Houston his roommate came
to the crash scene super friendly and
happy to be a family man he won his own
family and he got it
for a short time as the cargo plane was
approaching Houston from Miami Saturday
afternoon air traffic controllers warned
the pilots of rain ahead then silence
the question now is why did the plane
end up in a deadly dive the 767 is
widely used by major US airlines and
cargo haulers it's very unusual the
safety record of the Boeing 767 is
exceptional investigators sifting
through the debris were met with
conditions worse than the NTSB expected
the key here is to find the black boxes
they're likely somewhere in this debris
field back here this is what's left of
that 767 it came down in shallow marshy
water we will do what it takes even if
it involves getting in there and
grudging it out
we feel that it's critical that we find
those recorders for CBS this morning
Kris Van Cleave Anahuac Texas